(uplifting music)
We're celebrating hometowns all season long.
Isn't this country amazing.
So many special places that we get to call home,
because there is no place like home.
And for second grade teacher, Tatiana Inise,
that's Washington D.C., our nation's capitol.
And she's about to show us around,
take it away, Tatiana.
Hey Drew, my name is Tatiana Inise,
I'm an elementary school teacher
right here in Washington, D.C..
Now, D.C. has been my home for the past couple of years
and I love it here.
One of the things I love about D.C.,
is it's rich history culture.
Now, we're about to go check out Union Market.
It's my place to hit up right after work.
So let's go.
(uplifting music)
My first stop when I come to Union Market,
I always go to Puddin'.
Puddin' is a New Orleans Southern comfort food,
all wrapped into one.
Honestly, the bread pudding is delicious,
but everything on the menu is delicious.
I normally order the shrimp and grits or the etoufee.
So if you're at Union Market, check out Puddin'.
(screen whooshing)
(upbeat music)
We're here at Meridian Hill Park,
which the locals actually call it Malcolm X.
Little note that I didn't even know
is was called Meridian Hill Park.
I've always referred to it as Malcolm X Park.
Now on Sundays, they have a drum circle.
And it's absolutely beautiful,
like, live music on a Sunday, why not.
It's my favorite place to come when I just wanna chill out.
Wanna walk my dog, go for a run,
it's just the peace in the middle of the city.
(screen whooshing)
(upbeat music)
All right Drew, that's just a little snapshot
into Washington D.C..
I hope you love it as much as I do.
Listen, next time you're in town, hit me up girl!
I'll see you soon.
(screen whooshing)
Well, thank you, Tatiana.
That was amazing. I love D.C. so much.
You cannot go there and not be awestruck by the history.
By the way, have you ever had a summer in D.C.?
Whoo! That is humidity.
I will tell you the cherry blossoms, the museums.
It's just, thank you for taking us through your D.C..
And we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)